alors robert marchand vient tout juste
de se rendre au contrôle antidopage et
il a terminé il ya tout juste une heure
sa course c'est donc un formidable
exploit qu'a réalisé sous nos yeux au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
cet homme robert marchand je vous le
rappelle 105 ans l'homme qui a connu les
deux guerres mondiales et 16 président
de la république il a réussi à battre le
record de l'heure il a réalisé 24 5 km
avec une vitesse moyenne de 22 km heure
alors pour nous parler de cet exploit
jean michel richefort quitter dans le
team
du coup de robert marchand alors
jean-michel cet exploit vous surprend-il
oui c'est exceptionnel bien sûr je suis
surpris je suis je suis ému il n'y a pas
de mots parce que mon coeur a battu très
fort pendant pendant sept heures on l'a
entraîné ces derniers jours on était sur
des bases de 40 secondes au tour
et là il a toujours été en dessous du
tableau de marche le plus optimiste il
faisait des tours à 38 secondes à 37
secondes ce qui a été absolument
prodigieux et je craignais une grande
dans les dix dernières minutes mais il a
une telle volonté d'y arriver
il est allé au bout de sonneurs sans
problème
et sans doute vélo c'est la joie de
vivre voilà il a parfaitement récupéré
après trois minutes après trois minutes
son coeur était redescendu à 80
pulsations/minute ces produits même
terminé plus fort qu'il n'avait commencé
oui bien sûr il a accéléré accéléré et
dans le dernier quart d'heure après il
est redescendu imams et des détours à 36
secondes
j'avais un peu peur je craignais
justement que ça aille trop vite mais
non je pense qu'il était bien il était
bien et à tous les tours il faisait un
petit signe de tête ça va lui dire qu'il
était parfait il a peut être été
également poussé à 1 par le public oui
il était poussé par le public et puis il
a toujours la volonté de bien faire et
avec robert il faut calmer le jeu quoi
c'est vraiment la marque d'un champion
de vouloir se surpasser surtout vous
faire plaisir parce que il est bien il
est avec ses copains il est avec ses
amis le vélo pour pour lui c'est du
plaisir chaque jour il fait du vélo il
s'entretient il fait de la gym
donc c'est son moteur en quelque sorte
est aujourd'hui bon avec ses copains de
l'ardéchois ses copains de mitry mory
qui sont venus l'encourager
donc voilà que du plaisir pour lui je
pense et ce n'est peut-être pas terminé
dans deux ans robert marchand pourrait
battre un nouveau record